es Estados Unidos el país que no deja de
regar con armas el campo de batalla
respondido y Beijing a las últimas
acusaciones de Washington según las
cuales chinas estaría planteando el
envío de armamento a Ucrania dijo el
secretario de estado Anthony blinken que
disponía de pruebas pero no aclaró
cuales eran estamos pues ante una
situación muy parecida a la de marzo del
año pasado cuando Estados Unidos anunció
el envío inminente de armas chinas a
Ucrania que nunca se produjo lo que
parece recomendar ciertas dosis de
escepticismo China ha defendido siempre
su neutralidad escrupulosa se ha
ofrecido como mediadora en contraste con
el envío de armas de occidente china por
un lado en raras ocasiones a mencionado
la palabra invasión y segunda la teoría
de Moscú de qué conflicto fue originado
por la expansión de la otan por el otro
ha repetido que la soberanía territorial
de Ucrania tiene que respetarse y un año
no ha enviado ni una sola cantimplora a
las tropas rusas el conflicto colocó a
China en una situación muy complicada
escorada hacia
Moscú en su propósito de mitigar El
poder de Estados Unidos en este
ecosistema mundial pero también con la
necesidad de preservar su sintonía con
Europa entrar en guerra para china
supondría no solo romper todos sus
principios sagrados de su diplomacia
sino también atentar contra sus
intereses más concretos